un muro de países contra rusia los
primeros ministros de polonia república
checa y eslovenia miembros de la otan
llegaron hasta la sitiada que para
mostrarle su apoyo al presidente
ucraniano y aunque volodymyr silencia
aceptó que su país no entrara en la
alianza trasatlántica insistió a las
naciones que lo integran que le envíen
asistencia militar para defenderse de la
invasión de rusia
si no podemos entrar por las puertas
abiertas tenemos que cooperar con las
plataformas y los sindicatos que nos
permitan hacerlo nos ayudarán a
protegernos por ejemplo con sus
plataformas y nos gustaría también tener
garantías individuales
la mayoría de los países que rodean
ucrania son miembros de la otan y han
formado un muro de contención a
excepción de belarús quien al principio
del conflicto facilitó en su territorio
la llegada de tropas rusas y el
lanzamiento de misiles contra ucrania y
hungría país que a pesar de ser miembro
de la alianza le compra petróleo y gas a
moscú y cuyo primer ministro viktor
orbán tiene buenas relaciones con el
ruso vladimir putin desde hace más de 10
años precisamente este martes en un acto
de campaña para las parlamentarias del
próximo 3 de abril el primer ministro
húngaro
una postura de no intervención en el
conflicto
nuestro interés es que no nos
convirtamos en víctimas de la guerra de
otra persona de esta guerra no tenemos
nada que ganar sino todo que perder
debemos permanecer al margen de esta
guerra el partido de derecha de víctor
orbán se enfrentará por primera vez
desde 2010 al frente unido conformado
por 6 partidos de oposición en los
comicios se elegirán 199 miembros de la
asamblea nacional que deben elegir al
primer ministro de hungría para el
período 2022 2026